he said do you think that you could
scream just a little louder
[Music]
i was in my office and all of a sudden
from behind me this man in the mask
a killer came up and stabbed me several
times
and i had tubes coming up my
shirt and with slits in my shirt a wes
uh craven who is the brilliant director
of the late
great wes craven he said
do you think that you could scream just
a little louder
i said i can do that so we had to change
and clean up and get my blood off
and then all of a sudden boom then he
took a picture of my
eye which was maybe the longest shot
i've ever been part of
in order to get the reflection of the
killer
in my eye when i died
oh i would be superintendent of schools
and uh still be uh
you know not capable
[Music]
craft service is always my favorite
table now
uh because of the pandemic i bet the
craft service table you have to bring
your own treats
but the the mid-morning meal
and if it were a
a mid-morning meal of indian food
i would be ecstatic
but then i've worked on productions
where the entire
treat table is a can of pringles